amy fillmann o é vídeo novo o web de
novo e ainda nem assistir ao canal todo
bom vocês comigo o fato do bolão que eu
tô sofrendo bullying com meu nome for
não é tão difícil assim pra quem já me
conhece meu nome é o inverso nunes
e pra quem não me conhece meu nome é
joão quando a pessoa não me conhece eu
prefiro dizer que meu nome é joão pra
não ficar tentando convencer essa pessoa
de que o indexação é o nome fácil é
porque sempre faço uma moto que eu tô
gravando é macumba não é tão difícil
o endereço é só você trocar o hd o
anderson por yeo widerson pronto o
inglês acabou face a professora na sala
de aula maria da penha assessor joão
presentes o anderson o anderson gente
não tem nem um ano essa equipe que botar
o anderson professora é o inglês sul
hilde são o inglês on e wilson
ing/dreyer sol o william widerson zé
roberto e arroz desgraça na verdade
falar é fácil escrever é difícil demorei
da 1ª a 8ª série para aprender a
escrever o nome parece o caso que foi
registrado no bateu a cabeça no teclado
sabe como é conhecido o seu filho joão
né
então parece que não tinha escolha do
que escolher meu nome sei lá como é
conhecido no seu filho não pode botar
qualquer um pode escolher a anta beleza
widerson é o anderson não o inverso
willians não moça o endereço zé roberto
eu não gosto muito meu nome porque é
muito complicado sabe aquela pessoa que
tem nome bonito e pesquisa no google
significado do nome sempre tem uma coisa
que estimula a pessoa viver sabe tipo
robert obra significa o que brilha na
glória e o inversor velho windows
windows andares em que polga é essa mãe
falou que se não fosse o endereço ia ser
fábio é que a esposa tem um significado
do [ __ ] fábio pesquisei no google
fábio significa plantador de feijão é só
mais um endereço onde eu fui na caverna
com dois colegas meu o chamava walter eu
chamava jorge quando se falava perto da
caverna te dava um eco sabe é meu colega
falou jorge a caverna jorge jorge
já é meu colega falou walter taverna
volta e vão te ver
acho que perde a cabeça e falei a
impressão acaba neo que me vou sofrer
bullying das pessoas tudo bem mas o
freiburg de uma caverna pai foi depois
que espera não é ruim de som a elas é
roberto zé roberto então pessoal esse
foi o vídeo de hoje muito obrigada
torrão mosquito já tá aqui de novo então
pessoal esse que foi de hoje muito
obrigado com ou sem ter assistido se
você ainda não está inscrito neste canal
e quer saber quando tem vídeo novo é só
clicar aqui embaixo em inscrever-se
através que houve algo de novo apareceu
windows enviou o vídeo para dar aquela
moral é aquela força para continuar
fazendo vídeos é só clicar aqui e gostei
pra saber que você curtiu neste vídeo
você conhece alguém ou tem alguma pessoa
da sua família primo e um amigo que tem
um nome estranho se sim comenta aqui
embaixo nome alguma coisa estranha que
aconteceu com essa pessoa aí as pessoas
que me seguem no twitter ficaram sabendo
primeiro desse vídeo então se você quer
saber de coisas que ninguém sabe me
segue no twitter que é esse aqui ó
rowan williams outra coisa pessoal eu
estou lutando muito para tentar manter
esse canal tentar botar minhas idéias no
youtube que a descrição do vídeo tem um
link se chama vaquinha online as pessoas
que me assistem vão poder me ajudar a
comprar alguma coisa pelo meu canal por
exemplo a câmera eu tô pagando esse
tripé emprestado não é meu não tenho
muitos alunos que usa do sol mesmo
graças a deus jesus abençoe o piauí com
muito sol mas eu quero fazer as coisas
mais profissionais e tenho muita idéia
minha cabeça eu escrevo muita coisa no
meu computador mas pra isso eu vou
precisar de um tripé e outra câmera
vou precisar de gente para me ajudar
então tudo isso tudo isso vai precisar
de ajuda e nessa máquina online você vai
poder me ajudar a comprar essas coisas e
vai fazer se vai entrar neste link e lá
vai ter assim um jeito que você me
ajudasse e cadastre seu nome do soldado
telefone se diz o valor que você quer me
ajudar você pode clicar em boleto você
imprimir o boleto e paga na casa
lotérica pode ser r$7 10 reais 15 reais
em reais mil é ai qualquer coisa você me
ajuda muito obrigado então é isso
pessoal obrigado ea tema